thanks to the organizers for inviting me
to come here and chat with you they
asked me to come here and talk about the
researcher perspective and you know I'm
not really a random researcher okay
randomly selected researcher I'm trained
as a computer scientist and worked in
biomedical informatics for many many
years so I thought it would be really
interesting to talk a little bit about
the antagonism for contradiction or
tension between the incentives and the
interest of data scientists and bench
scientist here because it's really
important to navigate this if we're
going to actually make any progress and
everything I have to say is going to be
really connected to the biomedical world
which I know I can't say very much about
the humanities which I a field that I
respect very much but I just don't work
in it so how can you bring together the
perspectives of this the computational
folks and the actual wet lab guys right
and clinical researchers so just to give
a little background so it you know in
our world so NIH very very concerned
about scientific reproducibility and
robustness of results and and there are
a number of sort of drunk drivers for
this there was some famous papers in the
biostatistics world going back to 2005
unitas paper most scientific research
findings are false according to you need
us it may be an exaggeration but I mean
he's got a point that there are a lot of
probable false positives in the
literature begley analysis lure
researchers at amgen a big biotech
company showed that
roughly ninety percent of the research
results from biomedical academic labs
that were transferred into their farm at
Target discovery programs to work on
roughly ninety percent of them they
could not even reproduce the experiments
this is bad right and then it and then
there's a question about robustness of
results sort of through the
pharmaceutical development pipeline so
after you take only ten percent of the
academic research results that have
transferred successfully and take them
through the whole process of drug the
drug screening and all that sand through
clinical trials an additional ninety
five percent drop out that's a lot of
failed to research really in terms of
treating health problems so of course
NIH is very concerned and they've taken
undertaking a number of initiatives
around this and this comes at the same
time that we have a number of important
science policy studies recommending that
all primary research data be archived
and directly cited in the articles just
as publications are cited so to be very
clear what this means is that if I
publish some new research I put my
dating in an archive and then I say my
data show that X here's my
interpretation there's a citation with a
resolvable identifier like a DOI that
goes right to the archive data and that
it appears in the reference list just as
if it were a publication NIH one of the
things that NIH is done is it started
something called the big data to
knowledge program they actually now have
a Directorate of data science that's
headed up by Phil Bourne who came from
UCSD and the first aim listed on their
website for that program is to
facilitate you reuse or broad use of all
the
digital assets in biomedicine by making
them discoverable accessible and sizable
okay so that's sort of driving a lot of
interest in concern about this whole
that the data deposition and archiving
[Music]
idea from the standpoint of actually
incorporating the Mint's into the
scientific communications life cycle in
a robust way and do a bunch of people
that you know have similar research
interests to me are very interested in
the ideas of using these things as big
data right and exploiting them and
there's now going to be an open science
prize that the nih wellcome trust and
hhmi howard use our sponsoring that is
going to have probably have somewhat of
a focus in this area and people are very
interested in applying that your
incredible advances going on right now
in what its so called deep learning
methods and in fact they heard a talk a
couple of days ago in peter sorors lab
at the Medical School at Harvard Medical
School and by a deep learning researcher
who said by the way academia has hardly
any more deep learning researchers left
because they are all being scarfed up by
Facebook Google all these companies but
they are still publishing amazing things
happening that is how you have things
like self-driving cars right but can you
apply these to scientific research data
from the biomedical field and use this
to help cure diseases right there are
dear folks like Zach kahani at my
institution who actually you probably
know is the director of the count way
library but also a computational
biologist who are really interested in
mining electronic health records in in
combination with open genomics data so
the you you
the EHR data as a tree and this is
another machine learning type approach
you use the EHR data as a training
target you use the genomics data it's a
feature set and you try to train your
algorithms to recognize whether certain
patterns in the genome can are
predictive of having certain disorders
so all that's great and all the data
scientists love this idea and folks like
Professor kahani love this idea we have
a little project going on this field in
this area too for Alzheimer's a little
it little unique and we're hoping it
successful there's a big gotcha so
so as my friend and mentor Carol goble
said biologists would rather suck share
their toothbrush then share their data
and your definition of data mining in
biology is my data is mine in your data
is mine okay you'll note so this image
here came from a talk by Dave the roar
from Oxford the aphorisms from Carol
goble and by the way they're both
computer scientists okay so already
you're seeing there's a little pension
here we have a jaundiced view of the
ownership pretensions of the wet lab
biologists to their own data I put own
in quotes so this opens up the question
of motivations and incentives so who is
motivated towards open data science
policy makers they want to make the
science right and make it productive NIH
cure diseases data scientists great i
can do more research on your data bench
scientist nope their excuses will call
them because i'm speaking from my
perspective are i published my data i'll
get scooped if i did all the work why
would anyone else have the benefits it
is my precious my postdoc can sit
somewhere oh wait he left for Italy now
but there's another side to this and you
can sort of I don't want to be too
provincial about this as a data
scientist data scientists can be quite
extreme on this topic and I think it's
very unproductive the way some of this
is coming out all data must be published
in RDF if you don't know what that is
it's a resource description framework
that's a Semantic Web term column
headers must be normalized to a formal
ontology specified in w3c web ontology
language so i can use my cool semantic
web tools on it it's obvious that's an
important goal isn't it and when we talk
about you know biomedical ontology very
important in biology the national center
for biomedical anthologies at stanford
has 468 of them catalog with over six
million classes what's these are web
ontology Zand formalized as description
logic so a class means a term five-term
why can't the bench biologists may
answer all these terms reasonable to me
the ontology is our precious our ring of
power so there's attention and it's it's
a little tricky because remember a few
slides ago I've lined up the clients
funders and in or I should have said the
science funder via NIH the science
policy people in the data scientists
we're all in the same boat right we're
all big advocates of open science open
data so maybe we're going to gang up on
those bench scientist but if we gang up
on them and and try to make them do
something that's way over the top and
it's sort of too much for them to bite
off they'll just gain the system they'll
find a way to get away with not doing it
right and doing it
no in a way that they can live with the
point is how can you how can everybody
live happily when you have counters
incentives when you have publish or
perish right and there's we want to
publish but we want to publish on your
data mr. bench biologist no no sorry my
data and i'll choose the data scientists
with whom i collaborate and he'll be on
the paper and I'll control the
publication and by the way I will be the
senior author data scientists will be
the middle author I forgot to mention
the publishers so they're also actually
and peculiarly incentivized towards open
data because actually you need beer
article okay it's theirs because they
control it to understand the data the
pretensions of we semantic web workers
notwithstanding some of them like
elsevier are working towards very large
big data infrastructure's which they
hope to monetize surprise so
maybe this is a fool's errand but I
think that it's important to achieve
harmonization I think that we should
require data archiving to achieve
publication I think that we are we have
the possibility to get there if we
smooth the path for authors and
publishers and make it a gentle ramp
rather than walking up to a 400-foot
cliff and we should listen carefully to
my friends and colleagues the semantic
web and data science people but do not
let them go crazy that is a recipe for
disaster as well we all want to be
around the table and incentivize even if
we all have different perspectives and
come from somewhat different places we
want to be incentivized to come to the
table and participate so so I said that
there were science policy initiatives
and in studies that recommend the data
citation there was a harmonization
effort undertaken for those back in 2014
called the joint declaration of data
citation principles I was involved in
that but he did not organize it but it
was organized by colleagues of mine in
an organization called force 11 future
of research communication and II
scholarship and very important and I
think there were people here that were
involved in this right yes and it
brought together people from the
National Academies Library of Congress
code data and so forth to boil all these
studies which otherwise I believe would
have become shelf where as is the fate
of all big studies to eight principles
then something that I did actually lead
subsequent to that was another force 11
working group to develop
the implementation guidelines these are
principles will great and over 90
organized a hundred organizations
including a lot of publishers signed up
as endorsing these principles which was
pretty cost-free for them because they
were only principles so we developed
some tools and guidelines that we
thought would be useful in actually
showing people how to implement them and
the big ones were we revised the jacks
the journal article tag suite which is
an XML schema that lots of publishers
use and the PubMed Central and other
people use archived article we modified
it to support citing data and we got the
the National Information standards
organization to sign off on that so
that's out there now it's a tool and we
published an article with some
co-authors in this room recommending
certain things that need to be done on
the repository side and so forth so so
that's helpful we're now taking another
step what we have funding from NIH data
science Directorate to run a one-year
data citation pilot for early adopters
so people journal publishers who are
really ready organizationally to
implement data citation to get them to
actually sign up to get it off the
ground within the next year so our idea
is point of publication is point of
leverage get the adopters on the Earl at
the same page and provide long-term
incentives long-term incentives for the
data scientists delayed gratification
eat dessert last so the objectives
coordinating guide we want to get one or
more benchmark implementations of data
citation in real journals in in their
production process across some key use
cases and the book the focus is not cite
not really citing data that's already
been deposited which is important but we
thought the most important thing is when
I'm publishing this data
backing my findings in a new research
study because that's the point where you
get the stuff into the archives and
hopefully the biggest thing will be
actual implementations in the field and
then we will report on the lessons learn
to the community and will change any of
the recommendations that are out there
that turn out to not be workable in
practice these are some of the
participants up I think it's interesting
and thank you very much columbia
university is a participant and if you
want to find out more about it you can
click that link and I guess you're going
to put this up someplace so people can
access it and I always like to provide
references from my client references and
that's all really all I thank you very
very much
[Applause]